Sam rode in and said hey David do you
support life in prison without parole in
all cases where people would otherwise
get the death penalty and would you
apply life without parole to murderers
in general there is no one answer to
this question for so the difficult
wording here is let's take the first
question do I support life in prison
without the possibility of parole in all
cases where people would otherwise get
the death penalty otherwise get the
death penalty it is a sort of a vague
term I disagree with the death penalty
and I disagree with the sort of
incarceration industrial complex that we
have in the United States so no I would
not be comfortable making such an
umbrella statement as any case in which
someone would or could get the death
penalty the penalty should instead be
life in prison with no parole merely
because I don't agree with the death
penalty you've got to look at these
cases individually there are cases right
now where somebody would get the death
penalty in certain states that I would
realistically feel should get maybe life
in prison with the possibility of parole
depends on the person's age depends on
the nature of the crime committed so I
think such an umbrella statement is very
it's the type of black-and-white
thinking that I've been sort of trying
to tell our audience you should be a
very very skeptical of the second
question is what I apply life without
parole to murderers in general the term
murderer again is a complex term we have
premeditated murder
we have spur-of-the-moment moment of
passion murder
we have manslaughter which is considered
a form of homicide depending on the
state in which it takes place which is
sometimes called murder colloquially you
have a drunk-driving where someone dies
you have a bar fight where someone ends
up falling and hitting their head I know
of a specific some when I went to high
school that this happened to and it's
just a fight where two people punched
each other one person happened to fall
hit their head on something and died so
when we say do I support life in prison
without parole for murderers in general
again the answer is to say it all
cases is not something that I can get
behind and we need to really apply more
critical thinking more nuanced and quite
frankly I don't this is not to attack
this question from Sam because it's a
perfectly reasonable question I think
that unless we are able to step back
from these sort of principles only
analyses of politics as I've and and
society and culture as I've said before
we're not really going to get anywhere
and figuring out real circumstances that
exist in the complex real world and this
is why I've been critical of the
principles only movement there are
movements online I won't name them many
of you know which ones they are which
say we'll all that matters is principles
we value liberty above all else really
well what do you mean by above all else
because we can pretty quickly come up
with some situations in which you might
go back and say well yeah but that now
Liberty needs to be sort of couched in a
particular way or narrowed in a
particular sense it's perfectly
reasonable to come up with a list of
principles precepts and sort of
overarching ideas that govern your
political philosophy and how you
interpret the world around you but most
of the hard work is actually done in
figuring out complex situations that
contradict that have multiple values
that you might find important but that
contradict each other in some way and
that that's the type of thinking I'm
hoping to get more and more people to do